what's up everyone this is anthony pop
leone Oh most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off-the-chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off
Rob hey own aka crypto Bobby is the
founder of proof of talent and also host
of the popular YouTube channel crypto
Bobby in this conversation we talked
recruiting in the cryptocurrency
industry the do's and don'ts of the
interview process and how engineers
business development executives
management data analysts and marketers
can enter the cryptocurrency industry I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well skirts girl want to
know who has the best URL crypto comm
that's right crypto calm there are
crypto platform with one goal mother in
mass adoption that's why we're all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto calm is helping people do
that through buying earning lending and
card payment everything you could want
at crypto calm go help your boy out tell
them pump sent you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get in the mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine comm tell
them tom sent you and thank you later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by inch
account users can now securely store
their Bitcoin or ether at block 5 and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
in cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly high
rate it's the best rate in the industry
I highly suggest you go check out block
Viacom / pump again that's block by com
/ pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today if you follow Bitcoin and
crypto you've probably heard of eToro
they're the world's number one social
trading platform and I love it they've
got more than 10 million other traders
that love it - and guess what they just
launched the United States eToro offers
access to the world's most popular
crypto currencies including Bitcoin
etherium and others with the smartest
trading tools and the ability to connect
with the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
training feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and using Taurus social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or o comm again that's eToro
comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp lion-o
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by palm or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got a
special treat the one the only crypto
Bobby
aka real name Rob but crypto Bobby
thanks for coming to do this thanks for
having me I appreciate the time
absolutely
we got the live stream going people are
being obnoxious as usual I think that we
just saw I love you a couple of times
we'll have fun with this background what
did you do before you became Krypto
Bobby a couple different things so I my
first job at college was in IT
recruiting so I did IT recruiting in
Washington DC for a few years that's
actually where I found Bitcoin a buddy
of mine sent me an article that was in
December 2013 like the one of the big
kind of original like Bitcoin bubbles
and the article was I think was a birch
article and it was like the Bitcoin is
so 2013 dogecoin is 2014 and I was like
what is dogecoin what's Bitcoin and
naturally the first thing I did that
night when I went home was I read more
about it and found out that you could
use your computer to earn free magic
Internet money so I went ahead and
washed the YouTube video and started
mining dogecoin that night and then what
alleged my since my first first job out
of college I didn't exactly have a ton
of money so I also did what any
entrepreneurial young chap would do is I
signed up for a bunch of free credits
for Microsoft Azure and Amazon Web
Services and all the cloud providers and
started mining dogecoin and then Bitcoin
through that as well so did that ended
up moving into ended up moving into
software sales worked at Oracle and and
LinkedIn for about five years or so and
kind of made my way into crypto after
that alright so you were taking the free
credits and trial like services from AWS
and Microsoft Azure and you were using
that to mine crypto yeah so I'd be smart
actually I mean it was like a hundred
dollars of free credits and I was
probably making god knows not much money
at all but it felt like a smart idea at
the time probably was a huge waste of my
time but it was something where I was
just kind of getting familiar with it
and I was in the process of getting a
master's degree in information systems
at the time and the process of
creating these different servers than I
was running and feeling like I was doing
something interesting and technical was
kind of appealing to me so I went
through that and then I ended up buying
the little for a while you could
actually mine Bitcoin with these little
USB mining Asics so I bought a bunch of
those and just had those running I had a
desktop computer at my office so I had
those running 24/7 at my desktop
computer with a little fan that was
blowing on at all times because
otherwise they would basically melt your
computer so that was kind of like how I
ended up getting into it it wasn't
necessarily like I really understood the
kind of the finance elements or the
economics elements behind Bitcoin or not
necessarily dogecoin dogecoin was fun
for a while but I didn't necessarily
understand those components as much as I
was really interested by the fact that
you could like basically print money
from your computer which as a 23 year
old kid I was like oh this is kind of
appealing so I kind of dove in that way
got it how do you go from essentially
beg borrow and stealing computing power
to mine crypto to the infamous crypto
Bobby like what occurs in mining Bitcoin
and dogecoin to having what how many
subscribers on YouTube it's like a
hundred thirty thousand something like
that so got a hundred plus thousand
subscribers on YouTube and you started
out using free credit side AWS like
what's the transition um so I mean it
became pretty unprofitable to to do
anything like the free credit student I
probably did that four or five times so
it wasn't necessarily like I was paying
rent with that I probably made a hundred
bucks maybe but even the mining with the
Bitcoin Asics became pretty unprofitable
pretty quickly so I just kind of stopped
that and would kind of dollar-cost
average into Bitcoin on occasion and
really just focused on my day job which
was recruiting and then software sales
for about two five years up until 2017
and I was working a job in enterprise
software sales at at Oracle I sold erp
software which is accounting software
yeahit's I sold that to financial
services firms in New York City so it
was really exciting paid well but yes I
did that for I did that for a while and
I actually worked from home for the most
part so there was a specific day it was
like August of 2017 I made a video there
wasn't a ton of content about crypto at
the time or a ton of content that I
loved a lot of people talking about
crazy things and talking about bit
connect and that just the YouTube game
was kind of Wild West back then and why
don't you just kind of put my thoughts
together on what I felt like I had a
different spin to say and I put the
first video out there got like 50 views
the second one got like 500 and the
third one got something like five
thousand I was like this is an
interesting growth pattern and maybe I
should continue to do this and so for
like six or seven months I made a video
on YouTube basically every single day
sometimes twice a day and that kind of
just took off and was a pretty crazy
ride yeah
what were the videos about so the videos
were about everything from like daily
price movements in Bitcoin to aetherium
to what alt coins were doing and just
different like trends that I saw and I
tried to be not too high level at all
because I'm not necessarily the most
technical person or I acted like I know
more than a lot of people but I'm
definitely not in that like upper 2% as
far as knowledge so I definitely wanted
to be in a position where it wasn't just
kind of like a relatable individual when
talking about crypto and I think kind of
what what something that was fun for me
and also just help the channel grow a
lot was I did these like crypto happy
hours which were kind of like this but
it would be 9 o'clock at night and I'd
have three beers and sit on a livestream
and just interact and answer questions
and kind of listen to what people have
to say and talk to him about things so
and with a hundred plus thousand
subscribers when you do that like how
many people aren't at any time a couple
hundred so it right now it's probably
like three two to four hundred
in the peak of the the Borah yeah what's
going on it's a full run that was that
was the most while there was one time I
was sitting in you know sitting in my
like office at home recording a live
stream and there were 4,000 people on
the live stream and I was just sitting
there with the with a couple beers to me
just like what what is there are 4,000
people that are watching this and Here I
am like the next morning waking up at 8
o'clock in the morning to have a
discovery call about accounting software
and there's 4,000 people that are
watching this and that was it was like
mind-blowing that that's like a small
stadium like literally it's like you're
like a stand-up comedian and you made it
you're performing front of 4,000 people
right yeah it doesn't it doesn't last
long because it's uh it's totally
correlated with the crypto markets but
yeah it was it was a wild wild time okay
and so you go explain the crypto happy
hours that you're streaming live you're
drinking right not getting drunk it just
you know you're having a beer or two
what does everybody else do and it was
the idea that they're gonna be drinking
as well while watching the live stream
it was just kind of like whatever people
want to be doing like I typically the
majority of my audience would be
us-based so I would do it let's say
sometimes seven eight nine basically
after I was done with work I would log
in and then yeah I would
you know ask people like like how you
ask people on your stream hey where are
you watching in from outside where you
watching in from what are you drinking
and it would be you know everything from
like crazy ipas2 Bud Light to to vodka
on the rock whatever it might be so that
was always kind of a just a fun way to
interact with people and then would just
answer questions I mean a lot of times
it would be like what do you think about
XYZ should I invest in this should I put
all my money in that and a lot of times
I have I mean I have no idea but I would
just kind of try to provide some type of
rational thought process whether or not
that ended up working out in the long
run who knows I love it I love it
alright so what are you doing now no
longer selling accounting software so
when I was when I was doing the YouTube
channel or like doing a ton of that
which I still do now but I was like
really interested in the crypto industry
really interested in Bitcoin a theory
I'm a lot of the other things and I
really wanted to work full-time in the
space and for me I had difficulty doing
that because I have a software sales
background like my my job was to
generate revenue for companies or my job
was to generate revenue for Oracle I had
a whatever a million dollar million
dollar plus quota and my job would be to
close software-as-a-service deals and
that was difficult when I would be
looking in the crypto space because
there wasn't necessarily a lot of
companies that were a bringing in
revenue or be the types of companies
that were bringing in revenue or mostly
the crypto currency exchanges where
they're looking for somebody with a Wall
Street institutional finance sales
background which I just don't have so it
was really tough for me so what I was
eventually doing at that point in time
was I would apply to different jobs I
would just hear nothing back and a lot
of people would reach out to me about
interviews on the podcast and eventually
when I started to look at was okay if
somebody's reaching out to me about an
interview I am going to check their
check the company if I know of the
company
I'll check their website and I'll look
at it and say oh wow they actually have
a job opening so I've replied back to
there any of you and say hey you know it
love to have you on my podcast by the
way I saw you had a business development
role we'd love to talk to you about that
as well and that was something that
eventually kind of got my foot in the
door a little bit and I interviewed with
a company that you've talked to ovett
fluidity air swap so I actually
interviewed ovett on my youtube channel
and I was talking to him before the
interview and he's like what's your
endgame what are you trying to do like
well I'd love to work full time in the
industry and he's like come in on Sunday
came into the office on a weekend I met
with the team two weeks later made the
jump and left left Oracle to work in the
crypto industry full time how freeing
was it to shed the man and enter into
the world where people are free good
half-crazy and and and frankly half
overly ambitious it was it was it was
really interesting I mean I actually
really liked software sales if I if like
the Bitcoin industry as a whole wouldn't
come around I feel like I'd still be
doing that for sure I think that's a
great job for anybody that's that's ever
interested in that it's awesome but it
was really being interesting on Mayan
because when you just make content I
kind of felt like an outsider looking in
on the industry I was like okay I'm
making content I'm talking about this
stuff
but I don't necessarily know exactly
what's going on in the inside you know
there's not necessarily a ton of respect
in the in the world for you know
youtubers amongst the the like
established leaders of the industry so I
was just looking to do something where I
had an opportunity to actually
participate in what was going on within
the industry try to build things try to
learn things as much as possible and it
was it was really awesome to be able to
go into an office every day and just
like be able to work with like-minded
people who were passionate about Bitcoin
passionate about a theory I'm more like
really interested in seeing the industry
grow so that was that was my favorite
part about it and you go from that to
starting a business and yeah please talk
a little bit about what you're doing now
and kind of what the the genesis for
starting proof account was sure so in in
2019 I was still at at fluidity and
started to think a little bit just in
the in the back of my head about like
what like the long-term game in the
industry for me my excuse me might be
we're going so fast we need some water
so so thinking about that a little bit
more in depth is this is this like
crypto happy hour like in the morning
yeah despite coffee and if you have if
you have booze that'd be great now well
it's Friday right it's it's never too
early on a Friday on the live stream
think you need milk I don't know why but
that's what they're saying water for the
buffalo chicken cake thank you I
appreciate that
well we're gonna get to the Jets and the
buffalo chicken inaudible I thought the
Jets already plays it so I was just
thinking a little bit about like
long-term where I could add the most
value in the industry and
had the at the time what I thought was
kind of a crazy idea to start a
recruiting firm and I did a bunch of
research I was I was driving up to
Boston one day and kind of had the idea
that popped in my head and I was like
you know what this actually seems like
something that's not that crazy and I
did a bunch of research and didn't
necessarily find anybody that I thought
was kind of meeting the specific needs
of of the market and then I started to
reach out to different people that work
in crypto and run companies so I started
to reach out to different CEOs and this
is like hey I have a quick question for
you you know people that I knew people
that I was friends with I was like you
know what do you do for recruiting how
do you handle hiring what are your
thoughts do you see it demands and
basically every time there was just a
conversation about like some of the
business challenges when I was trying to
do some market research almost every
single CEO is like hiring is a huge
problem for us it's a really big issue
and we're just not able to hire fast
enough so just kind of put a bunch of
wheels into place and ended up ended up
deciding to leave full-time with
fluidity to start proof of talent which
is a technical recruiting firm that
works exclusively with companies in the
blockchain and cryptocurrency industry
got it
there's a lot to unpack here because one
I definitely agree that there is a ton
of people who want to hire yeah but
they're struggling maybe let's start on
that side with the companies sure like
what are you seeing or you're sitting in
them kind of the middle of that market
so you talk to employers everyday you
talk to people who are in the industry
looking to Swiss shop and then also
people outside the industry looking to
get into the industry on the employer
side like what are some of the trends
you see and some of the challenges that
they're facing
sure so yeah I think you summarized it
well I mean a basically proven practice
I last night I stayed up late to
practice that one little speech so proof
down is pretty much like a it's
basically a matchmaker between companies
that are hiring and and talent and so
for the companies that are hiring I
think you've seen and I've been
interesting just like with the industry
how things have changed as 2017 there's
definitely a somewhat of like a unique
perception where I feel like things have
the outside interest is maybe pared back
a little bit but it's definitely been a
lot more legitimized over time I think
every day that that Bitcoin continues to
exist and continues to succeed that's
the just kind of legitimacy for the
industry continues to grow and you're
starting to see companies that are I
think finding different and new unique
use cases and that's where I think like
for me that the majority of the
companies that I work with are trying to
fill those gaps I think previously you
know what you've seen is like the only
successful companies have been the
basically exchanges for the most part
like the companies I've done really well
I've been crypto currency exchanges and
in 2016 2017 you had a lot of token
sales and I CEOs with these lofty goals
and for the most part the vast majority
of them have have not panned out
and with that you have this kind of new
emerging class of a business that is
mostly like a venture backed you know a
venture back company that's building
some type of infrastructure or service
within the cryptocurrency world whether
that is research or data or like API is
around exchange there's a lot of
different nice niches and unique
components that businesses are kind of
going after outside of just the
exchanges and that is one of the areas
where I think people have have to kind
of prove their ability to succeed
because you have these companies that
everybody is building the next big thing
but kind of proving that you're able to
is really important when trying to
attract that that next generation of
talent all right so the employer side is
obviously the businesses are going to do
what they're going to do yep we already
have people asking in the live stream
things like college grad with
programming smart contracting experience
how can I expose myself to crypto dev
positions sure so let's flip around to
the other side of the market whether
somebody's been in the industry or not
what are you seeing from people who want
to fill these jobs from a trend
perspective sure so like if you're
looking at talent
what I would I typically see especially
in the technical side primarily proof of
town is a technical of recruiting firms
so about 70% of the positions we work on
or some type of software engineering
role the other 30% might be like a
smattering of business operations legal
but for the majority its its engineering
tech roles or development type roles and
for the most part companies are really
looking and interested in people that
have experience with like core
technology outside of the block chain or
cryptocurrency world you know whether
that might be like a back-end engineer
that has experience with Java or C++ at
a start-up or a larger you know tech
company or front-end engineer that's
worked with JavaScript and react for a
few years there's not necessarily as
much of a demand for that I'm seeing
right now at least there's not as much
of a demand right now for somebody that
has let's say experience specifically
working on Bitcoin or specifically
working with solidity and web 3 there
are opportunities like that but I for
the most part see that companies are
more strict on finding individuals that
have poor technology experience and less
strict with somebody having blockchain
experience going into it from day one
got it and then let's get into a little
bit of like advice yet people right so
what are some of the do's and don'ts
sure let start with the don'ts right so
there's a West people who they want to
get jobs and they either kind of shotgun
out to a bunch of companies they come to
you whatever what are the big mistakes
that they're making that they shouldn't
do anymore
so I think that and coming from somebody
that has been in this situation like I
said before know when I was at Oracle I
was sending out resumes and I was
basically hearing nothing back I wasn't
the perfect fit for for the positions on
paper but I still felt like I had
something to offer and I think a lot of
people feel like they're in that
scenario where you know they don't feel
like they're necessarily like they look
at the job description they know you
know hey I don't have everything but I
think I can add value and what I would
say on that end is that for the most
part the crypto industry is still small
enough where personal connections
think really make a big you know big
difference and so if you are somebody
that I think networking is is like a
huge huge thing to to be like successful
within the to be successful within the
then the job search is you know going to
if you're in a large city going to
different crypto meetups and trying to
meet people there or even like Twitter
and telegram are still I think hugely
important and helpful like you can be in
any location in the world and you could
still interact with people on a
consistent basis so I think building up
a network as much as possible and trying
to get warm introductions is something
that's helpful especially for people
that aren't maybe the best fit for
specific roles at least on paper skirts
girl want to know who has the best URL
crypto comm that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pomp
sense you download the app or visit
crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine calm tell
them pomp Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
ether at block five and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds
you receive a 6.2% APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump - sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
yeah and you never talking before we
started recording it's almost like this
idea of like giving value but or you try
to capitalize on it maybe explain a
little bit of that sure so one thing
that I think is really important for for
people that are not within they're not
working in the in the crypto industry
right now or in the the blockchain
industry maybe you're a college you
could be a cup you can be in college you
could be a college grad you could have
whatever 10 years of experience on Wall
Street doesn't necessarily matter I
think that proving your actual interest
within the industry is really important
and there's a couple different ways that
you can do that and why why I say this
is because a lot of people when you're
when you're having I have conversations
with job candidates multiple time today
and there's a lot of times where you
know your speak to somebody and say hey
I'm really interested in Bitcoin or a
theory or whatever it is and then I'll
ask is there is there anything that you
have that I can show to somebody that
can you know we can use that to to prove
your interest and for the most part
there's not there are a few people and
I've seen these people have a ton of
success where if it's somebody that's
non-technical they're analysts or a
researcher or they're just a they're
working in some type of business role
they write their thoughts down on medium
maybe they only have two articles but it
goes to show like hey I've given actual
thought to this industry and I've tried
to you know put some some time and
effort into what I'm doing and I'm
interested even if I'm working a
full-time job doing something completely
different
on the other end of the spectrum if
you're a software engineer one of the
easiest things that you can do is find a
project that you're passionate about and
contribute I mean the entire basically
the entire industry is built on an open
source source ethos so if you find
something that you like contribute a
little bit put in a you know put a
little bit of effort
in I just build up your github profile a
little bit and I think that will go a
long way as far as just ultimately
showing that you do care about this more
than just saying I do yeah it's almost
like do the job before you get the job
Yeah right and I like your example of
like the researcher because the
technical one I think is very obvious
right
oh you're interested in space build
something right now you can show people
this one I built and they they like it
or they don't they figure out can they
work with you or not the non-technical
positions though a researcher an analyst
it's so simple I just never totally
write the ones that are probably harder
and I want to hear your thoughts on or
like folks like business development
right or marketing how do you think
about what they can do before they
actually go in to apply for a job to
kind of show value or you know prove
their worth if you will in some cases it
might be doing something that's a side
project in addition to your full time
job you know if you're working in
marketing and you want to maybe help
somebody out for five hours a week on
the side that could be something that's
that's interesting there are you know or
if you're in sales maybe trying to help
somebody on the side there are a couple
different like Masari has they're like
analyst program i've talked to a bunch
of different people that they might be
working and they might be looking for a
research job maybe they don't they're
not looking for that at all but by
participating in that analyst program
it's basically like a free volunteer
program that they're doing but it's kind
of a resume builder and that's like what
they're looking at that's what they're
looking at it as and it could be
somebody that's working in operations or
sales trading on Wall Street it doesn't
necessarily matter but that type of just
like helping and kind of being involved
within the industry is is really
important for a lot of people absolutely
we've got people in the comments ah
Catherine Cooley CEO of Finance us
saying I am hiring looking for active
folks who successfully drove results at
scale versatility is key perfect example
of somebody who's saying look we're
hiring and we're looking for people who
can drive results and then actually have
skills but it's not necessarily how to
do it at the crypto industry etc right
yeah and I think to like when you just
job searching in general
and when you're applying for
opportunities it's you're trying to make
yourself the most attractive candidate
possible there are going to be you're
not going to be the only applicant for
these opportunities and you want to put
yourself in a position where your
background your resume is the most
appealing and not necessarily just like
your resume I think that's somewhat like
a little bit like out date in general
but like your your experience your
background what you bring to the table
is the most appealing thing to somebody
else and ultimately you have to sell
yourself to the company they have to
sell yourself they have to sell them to
you as well because hopefully you'll
have multiple opportunities that you can
choose from but that's something that
you know you want to always try to put
like the best package forward for a
company to look at for sure alright
we'll come back to hiring in a second
but I gotta I gotta ask two questions
one you're a fanatic when it comes to
buffalo chicken what uh what's going on
with that I never had a buffalo chicken
sandwich that bad yes that's uh that's
that's that's terrible I'll have to have
to buy one for you all right what's the
fascination all right so it was it was
kind of a running joke in like mid to
late 2017 when I started Krypto Bobby on
Twitter and on YouTube you know there
would be times where I'd go and I'd get
like a buffalo chicken for lunch and for
whatever dumb reason I would post it on
Twitter and then like 30 minutes later
the price of aetherium would be up 50%
or the price of Bitcoin would be up to
30% and I'd be like I need to eat more
buffalo chicken wraps and it just kind
of like turned into this running joke
and I also could eat like a buffalo
chicken wrap like three times a day
unfortunately I haven't found any like
super great ones in New York City so I'm
still still struggling for that but yeah
it just it it rolled all right so we're
gonna go from something you love which
by the way McDonald's if they had a
buffalo chicken wrap would be even
better
let me down to the best restaurant I'm a
big Mickey D's fan I'm a Mickey D's
stockholder so I hope it hope it goes on
forever that's what my brother my
brother has a local McDonald's knockin
ever we go somewhere outside the United
States days a nice dividend we literally
go to McDonald's he's like I'm checking
on my
investment I there's there been a few
times where I was in I think it was like
Dubai Malta a couple of there like ran
international places for crypto
conferences Prague and every time I go
and I get a Big Mac yeah yeah why not um
personally make chicken fan though a Big
Mac guy no I gotta go to meet chicken
all right we got to talk about a serious
topic now what the [ __ ] is going on with
the New York Jets I'm a die-hard New
York Jets fan I actually enjoy pain well
at this point in time no but yes by the
way as a New York Giants fan like I feel
for you right but go ahead so my dad was
a Jets fan so I naturally I begin with a
Jets fan it's funny because I actually
got a cold I went to the first game this
season and I got a cold call from the
season ticket office yesterday and then
I got an email and I did respond but I
was just kind of laughing in my head
like if there's if there's any worse
sales job on the planet right now than
selling Jets season tickets I don't know
what it is but I'm a huge Jets fan I'm a
die-hard Jets fan they're like the fact
that the season is basically over two
weeks in is the most I was so pumped
went to the first Jets game tailgated
super pumped blows the scores it was 16
nothing and they blew 60 no lead lost
1716 and because of two missed field
goals and then our starting quarterback
who's I think gonna be I think Sam
Darnell it's gonna be awesome but gets
mono and is out for at least a month and
I don't I haven't heard of a anybody
above like 15 years old getting mono
since I never so that's just that that's
the Jets luck is your starting
quarterback it's mono your backup
quarterback breaks his ankle and now
you're on some third shrink so there we
are
if it makes you feel better going into
the season for the New York Giants Eli
Manning you know when is he gonna turn
it over we're in week 3 and he's already
benched that's so so that tells you how
the Giants seasons calendar they might
be the only team worse than the Jets so
we can you have a Super Bowl in your
lifetime I'll never have that yeah that
issue we have two of them actually beat
the Patriots oh my god
all right so other than football and
raps where can people go if they're
looking for jobs in the space right with
proof of talent in terms of what's the
best way for them to get in touch with
you and they're working they go
sure so with proof of talent I'm really
trying to build a company that people on
the the job-seeking side really think of
as a place to go and reach out to us
when they are looking for opportunities
whether they're looking within the space
they're already working at a company in
the crypto industry or if they're you
know looking from outside they're trying
to you know to make their way in so
really trying to serve as a point of
contact for individuals on that end and
also for companies looking for companies
that are hiring that you need assistance
with technical talent or non-technical
talent a place that they you know that
they know and that they can trust to
help them find that talent as far as as
far as companies and individuals
reaching out proof of talent Co is is
our website there are a number of job
opportunities you can see there you
could send in your resume a bunch of
different things and also if you're
looking for different positions you
could certainly reach out as well and
then on Twitter my DMS are open which
slide in the DM is something I I had
closed DMS forever and once I started
the new business I was like you know I
they got to open them and that's been a
it's been an interesting experience well
what's the craziest thing and the most
valuable thing that you've been deemed
the the level of like c-level executives
at large companies that will come in to
just send you a message via Twitter or
on telegram it's pretty incredible I
think people like I post a lot about the
job opportunities on Twitter and people
are like you're never gonna find that
position on Twitter and then I have you
know a 20-year lawyer with experience
working at some massive financial firm
and the SEC that sends me a messaging is
like hey I'm looking for a job in crypto
I run I run a whitening node and I'm
really passionate about this stuff it's
like oh you can't find this type of
thing on Twitter Twitter's the new
LinkedIn yeah I still I still utilize
LinkedIn and I think that's it's it's
helpful but the the organic
conversations that you have on
on twitter or i think a lot more at
least for me just because that's like
where I have the most audience and I've
built up the most relationships there's
definitely more of a kind of an organic
feel I feel like yeah
what is the Twitter account and what's
the YouTube account so I'm never gonna
think of you is not crypto body so on on
Twitter I'm a crypto underscore Bobby
there's also a proof of talent if you
want to reach out about any job
opportunities you certainly do that
there and on YouTube it's just crypto
Bobby if you search it in no underscore
no it's just just crypto Bobby do we
know who has the a crypto Bobby no
underscore on Twitter I don't and the
only reason I'm actually crypto Bobby is
because I go by Rob for the most part in
real life but crypto Rob comm was not
available so I decided to buy crypto
Bobby calm so that was basically people
like what what why do you go by Bobby
I'm like just crypto Rob calm wasn't
wasn't available on GoDaddy I almost
don't want to admit this but uh I one of
the URLs I bought this long that I think
a pretty long time ago pomp Bitcoin calm
it's actually a pretty good one I'm
probably gonna do a jump but but the
fact that that was available and I got
it would maybe so happy
so whoever they got crypto rob calm but
I've got a buyer for you oh wow
facilitate a tree alright rapid-fire
questions most important company crypto
other than proof of talent ah definite
proof down now um I'm surprised no one's
fought me on this question like so no
one's ever really like no actually it's
our company I think that coinbase is one
of the most important and one of the
most interesting I feel like they've
they've done some kind of
eyebrow-raising moves in terms of I feel
like they've gone from one of the most
conservative companies in the crypto
space to hope you saw yesterday
considering adding a bunch of new
telegram and handshake and up like
probably 15 different assets so I feel
like they've definitely taken a more
retail approach and I I'm interested to
see how that pans out
for coinbase given their their user base
and their their pull on the industry
rather than some of the like more
institutional and a focused answers
around like ETS and things like that
yeah we'll see what's the one regulation
you would change or improve if you could
I mean I I think the vast majority of
the vast majority of people will say the
the credit investor laws as somebody who
as of recently previously was in New
Jersey resident and now I'm a New York
resident the bitlicense is super super
frustrating as a as a new New York
resident having to deal with that it's
something that I feel like every other
every different crypto exchange or
product or anything it's like we're
available in 49 states - New York so for
very selfish reasons and also because I
think it's or nurus for companies to
comply with the bit license is something
that I'd love to love to see changed at
some point they're either gonna have
state by state regulation or federal
regulation if the federal really
radiation comes to they may get rid of
the state regulation so we'll see that
would be nice
most important book you've ever read
there have been a lot of interesting
ones but I think my like favorite and
the one that's had probably the longest
lasting impression on me is shoe dog by
Phil Knight I think fantastic yeah it's
an awesome book and it just goes to show
especially now where you kind of see the
overnight success of a lot of people and
in like the the tech focused world and
with a lot of startups I mean companies
going to billion dollar valuations and
minutes and seconds basically it feels
like and I think Phil Knight going from
like eight thousand dollars in sales his
first year with Nike and wasn't even
Nike was Blue Ribbon - like 16,000
basically doubling in sales from
absolutely nothing to being a multi
multi billionaire over the course of
like 20 30 years is such like an
inspiring story just around dealing with
adversity so that's that's probably the
most interesting and important book for
it for me all right
aliens real or not
exist or don't exist I'll say they exist
yeah hey hey you don't sound very
confident I got it I got enough problems
on on earth right now that I got enough
things to worry about here so long as
they don't come down in an Independence
Day style fashion oh we need Will Smith
to save us I'm not too worried about
aliens higher probability of a human
being able to prove contact with an
alien or the Jets going 60 nano in your
lifetime definitely alien there's 0%
chance like negative 0% chance the Jets
will ever ever go 60 nano so yeah and if
they do they'll probably not make it to
the Super Bowl so yeah aliens definitely
the so I originally started asking the
question and people on the livestream
seem to remember alien bets that's where
it came from was I was laying in bed one
night and I was like if aliens showed up
would they have would it be like a
multi-species right where they have pets
and there's like the human equivalent or
they just all the same thing what do you
think it might yeah you know I feel like
the the pets is probably uh probably a
solid move I feel like it's very
presumptuous presumptuous of us to just
think that there's just gonna be one
race of aliens like there's probably
multiple yeah and we are their pets yeah
of course we are we are in the
simulation all right to finish up and
then we'll take a couple of questions
from the livestream less the podcast is
over what question do you have for me
[Music]
how do you view I don't distribute how
do you view distribution I feel like
that's something that you know just
about as well as anybody in the crypto
space and as underrated importance and
what would be curious just like general
your on your thoughts on on distribution
a highly controversial thought many
people would get mad at me for saying it
so I'm gonna say it and then it'll make
sense why every single piece of content
on the Internet is entertainment
so even the news is entertainment yeah
and
whether people like it or not it's not
the fact that I think that's the way it
should be
it's just a fact of life it's
entertainment and the second that people
start looking at content creation
distribution etc entertainment it
completely changes the way that you do
things right so if you look at it
there's a lot of people who have a
distribution strategy if I'm gonna
educate yep but if the educating is
boring and not entertaining you know
there's yeah right there's a lot of
people who say I'm just going to
overwhelm the market with content it's
not entertaining you don't get anywhere
right there's a lot of people say I'm
going to write the news I don't care if
you write the facts or not if it's not
entertaining
no one's gonna read it right and so the
the entertainment factor is either
misunderstood or
left out a lot of times what I think
that translates to it doesn't mean that
you have to be funny or have to have
high production quality from like a you
know hey we created a skit and here's a
video it's just the fact that eat and we
take this live stream for example
there's some people are watching they
might not understand 80% of what we're
talking about but the fact that we're
having fun we're laughing whatever like
it's entertaining to them so they keep
watching right they don't know if all of
a sudden what I was going to say some
crazy ass thing or whatever and so to me
distribution is entertainment
entertainment entertainment and I was
joking but I wasn't joking when I said
to somebody recently I said all the
marketing is the pre-work for the
important stuff right what I meant by
that is like all the entertaining and
the you know the tweets with the emojis
and trying to go viral and all stuff
it's just you're doing that to build
audience you're doing that to build up
impressions and eyeballs because then
when you have something important to say
or you're a business and you want to
sell your product or your you know for
you you've got a job opportunity that
you're trying to fill whatever all of
that pre work has become a habitual the
folks that they're paying attention sure
and then once you have that then you
capitalize on it by presenting the
important information right or whatever
the goal is I think that there's a lot
of people that they don't want to put it
in the pre-work because I think it's
stupid it's beneath them it's too hard
it'll take too long too
energy whatever it is and then what they
try to do is they try to capitalize but
it's like you haven't earned the right
to do the capitalization of your efforts
until you've done the pre-work you've
been entertaining etc and you know if I
said to you right now hey I need you to
go on YouTube and get a bunch people to
sign up for something sure you're just
cashing in social capital right like
like they're like yeah we know this dude
we paid attention like okay he likes it
I'll go do my own research feel like I'm
in and so from a distribution standpoint
it's it's the WWF like that is what
Twitter is if you look at Twitter there
are good guys bad guys there's heroes
there's villains there you know there's
all this stuff it's just entertainment
yeah it's I definitely agree with that I
feel like content is kind of like an
escape for a lot of people too it's you
know it's it's something to somewhat
distract from from the everyday and
there are I mean especially like crypto
Twitter and some of that you know some
of the elements around that it's such a
wild like unique world with like you
said so many different kind of types of
people subsets of the industry that take
a lot of kind of complex understanding
and different people trying to entertain
different groups so for sure so before
we shut off the podcast I'll leave you
with one comment that you didn't see
somebody just said the Jets are
entertaining I I would highly disagree
with you on that as somebody who was
sitting on my couch on Monday night
watching a pitiful 23 2 3 loss that was
not entertaining shout out wu-tang clan
10 I see you in the livestream I know
who you are you're hiding but I see you
alright I appreciate you coming on yeah
thanks a lot
hey everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way and
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the
chain